et après un duo un groupe de quatre les
beatles plus célèbre que jamais pour
célébrer à la fois les 50 ans de la
naissance du groupe et de la nasa
une de leur chanson est diffusée depuis
hier soir dans l'espace dans le cosmos à
la vitesse de la lumière
dominique marie c'est une première pour
le centre d'exploration de la nasa
habitué jusqu'ici à communiquer avec les
sondes spatiales
il a diffusé hier par ondes radio une
chanson des beatles à travers l'espace
univers c'est le titre du morceau choisi
difficile en effet de trouver mieux pour
célébrer les cinquante ans d'exploration
de l'agencé spatiale américaine
la chanson doit voyager à la vitesse de
300 mille kilomètres seconde avant
d'atteindre les toiles polaris 10 6 431
ans
enthousiasmé par cette initiative
l'ex beatle paul mccartney a demandé
avec humour à la nasa de transmettre son
infection aux extraterrestres mais il
n'est pas dit qu'une réponse soit
vraiment attendu depuis l'avènement de
la radio et la télévision
la planète terre et mais en fait depuis
des décennies des ondes radio à travers
les étoiles
pour le moment aucun programme ne semble
avoir séduit de forme de vie inconnue
les beatles auront peut être un peu plus
de succès